yo te retrouves sur the hill just est le
thé studio voilà c'est un peu comme
c'est impossible puisqu'on avait fait à
l'époque
sauf que là c'est encore plus con c'est
parti cliquer simplement sur square pour
commencer ben c'est là un bim bam boum
appuyé sur le gros bouton rouge pour
continuer cela appuyez sur le rectum
pour coter [ __ ] vous gâcher en train
de rechercher un quiz c'est incroyable
jamais fait un quiz aussi rapidement
appuyez sur le bouton rouge deux fois et
ensuite sur le bouton vert une fois
appuyé sur le bouton bleu trois fois
puis le bouton orange 4 x 1 2 3 2 3 4
attend s aidant oui j'ai un petit bug en
passant si on perd on recommence on
pense et je prie pour que nous bravo tu
as passé le premier niveau tu peux
maintenant tu es considéré comme un
c'est plutôt mignon comme un borderline
idiote
voilà c'est à dire qu'il était
finalement il veut pas traduire comme un
idiot au bord de la ligne hal et voilà
bonne traduction pour continuer cliquer
sur la photo d'un chat ok vidage de la
pression où vous pourrez re presseurop
euros en scène the d'un euro ou 3 ris à
faut cliquer des factions le clavier à
le petit piège de merde vous nous aurez
pas biatch 1 2 3 allez appuyé sur le
rectangle deux fois ouais t'as j'ai
c'est facile c'est un bon test à [ __ ]
à cuba sous votre rouge à les [ __ ]
c'est vraiment un test qui ont
effectivement bien jouer tu peux
maintenant de considérer comme un almost
average ce qui veut dire assez bien non
presque la moyenne voilà donc assez bien
jaffe 7 sur banc au cow boys et moi
quand je m'énerve vraiment dans la vraie
vie et pour continuer presse de xxl à
aller [ __ ] la faux souvenirs le jaune
une fois puis le bleu fil jaune jaune
bleu
jonah d'accord intense à quoi pour faire
quoi avec ses blagues d'accord à quoi
ressemble la formation des boutons à la
lettre r la lettre r bravo on est dans
la moyenne pour lui dans la moyenne
maintenant ça c'est le test de toute une
vie qu'on est en train de faire ok pour
continuer appuyez sur le plus petit au
bouton rouge et l' ue foule quoi si tu
veux réveiller alors appuyé sur ce gros
boutons mais attends mais non on
commence tout mec je vais péter un câble
[ __ ] ça commençait tellement bien ça
affreux ce qui se passe
attendez là je comprends pas mon erreur
il fait des blagues mais pas trop non
plus pas comme j'aime pas si folle quiz
pour continuer appuyez le plus petit os
il est là haut les fdp s'est bien jouer
bravo bravo the lights est le plus clair
c'est celui-là ah non [ __ ] squash quoi
ça [ __ ] je suis une merde chineurs
deçà va bien se passer a les moyens de
faire partie c'est reparti
le carré le plus éclairé c'est celui-là
ou celui-là os est bon de squaretrade
celui-là ouais c'est passé n'avait pas
sur le bouton vert tammet quercy car
dans ces questions il cherche juste la
couleur quoi c'est hyper rentable bien
jouer tu veux maintenant considéré comme
un kinda smart un tout petit peu
intelligent à les appuyer sur le bon
coup et quatre pour continuer un jaune
de atteinte attends attends au cas où va
prendre en photo ce que je pense qu'il
va demander la couleur du 1 à la
question d'après attendait basket
intelligence c'est aussi savoir utiliser
correctement ces différents outils y
compris son téléphone
4 bah voilà ça n'a aucun rapport
allez on peut on peut brûler cet iphone
in the oval te continue passer ça appuie
sur le cercle rouge du triangle bleu et
le rectangle vert sont le bleu rectangle
vert deux fois voilà c'est passé
peu importe ce que tu avais comme
quelqu'un d'intelligent pour continuer
appuyez sur le cercle vert juste là au
nom non fils de chien cette fois au lieu
de marquer n'a plus passé au groupe auto
il a marqué appui vite sur le gros
bouton et vu que je suis parfaitement
bilingue et que je mets très peu de
temps à traduire et ben on a réussi
cette question comme bouée loire vous
dire un oiseau oiseaux qui s'envolent
non c'est drôle ou pas est-ce qu'on
s'amuse dans cette vidéo
dites moi la vérité aux oiseaux
s'envolent mais jusqu'où ira-t-il au
plaza réussi à se trouve pas piller
[ __ ] les [ __ ] à ses très fourbe
appuyé sur le carré jaune pour continuer
c'est celui-là le caribou c'est celui-là
oh non il faut une drag queen règle on
va mesurer avec la boîte des gouttes
pour le nez tais toi et moi ça va à peu
près à la moitié
ça c'est pas un quart et ça c'est pas un
car et c'est celui-là je crois que non
c'est pas des carrés va dire cela
oy a cédé sa chute était mon bac et sa
bouille du marché la mesure avec ça soit
je suis con soit leur cas n'est pas un
carré voilà tout de suite vous pensez
que c'est moi qui suis content j'en ai
marre je démissionne voilà je remet ici
en aussitôt le bouton bleu trois fois le
bouton vert trois fois le bouton jaune
deux fois le 3 offert trois jaunes
d'oeufs
et ensuite rouge
voilà
la concentration la manga bravo vous
avez passé le test de l'idiot et tu peux
maintenant de considérer comme quelqu'un
de brillant c'est fini mais c'est facile
ce test là je n'ai pas besoin d'utiliser
la rue de la photographie choqué et déçu
j'ai pas trouvé de mots mais j'ai trouvé
une main s'écoule une main quand t'as
pas d'amis tu peux par exemple te
caresser comme ça ferraille five ouais
là ici tu peux bien évidemment aussi te
gratter les seuls à quoi vous pensiez
bordel oui mais les gens se souvient pas
de ces vidéos sur le test idiot bas je
pensais que ça allait être plus long
mais apparemment vu qu'on est
extrêmement intelligent l'a vraiment
fait rapidement on veut faire le test de
modestie bientôt
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça vous
appelez moi ça me fait bien marrer les
espèces de quiz comme ça ça change un
peu des jeux ça fait du bien c'est
important ça avance ça apporte un vent
de fraîcheur à la chaîne j'allais dire
ben seront bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo merci d'avoir regardé et je vous
dis tiens tout le monde
pissas